und passend dazu habe ich mir einfach
nichts bestellt
[Musik]
warte mal ich weiß was das ist
kennst das nicht willkommen beim ein
video ja natürlich geht es gut ich nehme
das ganze jetzt gerade schon im
nachhinein auch weil ich noch was sagen
muss und ich weiß gerade selber nicht
warum ich draußen steht aber es hat sich
so ergeben ich wünsche euch erstmal
natürlich fröhliche weihnachten falls
ihr weihnachten feiert ich hoffe ihr
weil reichlich beschenkt und habe eine
schöne zeit bevor dieses video losgeht
heute allerdings so kurz sagen ich habe
es ja irgendwie schon letztes mal
versprochen dass jetzt beim nächsten
video auf jeden fall das iphone verluste
die habs gerade auch übrigen mir fällt
gerade so auf diese jacke und das hemd
passt einfach so gar nicht ich hab nur
angezogen weil mir kalt war wir haben
ein iphone 8 in space grau glaubens oder
wie das heißt ist auf jeden fall ein
cooles handy ist ja die letzte sache aus
meinem adventskalender die jetzt verlost
wird ja bei dieser sache bringe ich ja
persönlich vorbei trotzdem machen willst
und teilzunehmen einfach für alle meine
abonnenten gibt diesen wieder nach oben
und schreibt so viele kommentare wie ihr
wollt und irgendein kommentar gewinnt
dann halt schreibt in die kommentare was
ihr wollt wie viele volt und sonst was
ansonsten wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß mit dem video das wir jetzt noch
gar nicht sagen willi so verlaufen ist
das macht man dann gleich viel spaß
hey leute was gesagt und jetzt
willkommen bei myvideo leute ich hoffe
jetzt gut ich muss mich jetzt echt
wirklich blind damals nicht zu laut
wegen weil ich habe heute etwas ganz
besonderes war
und zwar habe ich mir einen genialen
prank überlegt dass ich so geil ich bin
ja gar nicht ihr können dass mein bruder
ist genau und eben deswegen muss ich
auch leise reden ob ihr wisst ja
bestimmte alle vor ungefähr zwei monaten
oder so ist das iphone nichts
rausgekommen bisher echten geheimtipps
teil war auch am anfang sehr schwer das
zu bekommen und so ein iphone nichts zu
weihnachten ist ja echt ein mega geiles
geschenke das habe ich mir auch gedacht
ich darf mir
schreckte den bruder doch einfach ein
nagelneues iphone ickx und passend dazu
habe ich mir einen v6 bestellt das
problem ist nur ganz einfach war es aber
kurz bevor der ist leider schon ab ob
ich mein gut wer achtet jetzt darauf man
macht das ganze auf und man wartet jetzt
ja logischerweise hier darunter einen
kopflosen sogar drin
also man erwartet ja eigentlich einfach
nix ist allerdings kein iphone extrem
die komplett durch auch raus natürlich
bekommt auch normales geschenk von mir
aber hier müssen jetzt irgendwas rein
tun und dafür habe ich mir vor ich das
wallis und zwar habe ich hier einen sony
handy das problem ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon ein bisschen
kaputt das ding hat auch eine absolute
software fehler also das funktioniert
gar nicht mehr gut man könnte jetzt
natürlich reparieren lassen nur wenn man
das reparieren würde das wäre teurer als
würde ich einfach ein neues kaufen also
es praktisch nur das zählt jetzt
allerdings noch zu cool aus wir sind
schon echt viel her nichts kaputt
gehören und ich hab noch nie extra ins
kaputt gemacht und jetzt schauen wir ob
wir das live noch ein bisschen mehr
zerstören können eigentlich bräuchte es
ein stein wollte nach kurzem okay heute
perfekt also ich guck mal was ich machen
lässt macht das auf keinen fall nach das
handy ist kaputt ohne witz ich frag mich
so wenn iphones manchmal einfach so auf
den boden preise stumpf manchmal aus
blüten die er komplett aber wenn ich
jetzt weg hinten stehen drauf auch da
passiert gar nichts
erneute so sieht es auch soll dann
sprechen wir haben ein absolut
zerstörtes smartphone so jetzt legen wir
das handy hier rein passt das nicht mal
dort passt nachdem das fernsehen sowieso
das ganze werde es noch eingepackt das
heißt mein bruder macht gleich sein
geschenk auf sieht erstmal ein iphone
apps denkt sich bögerl ein von ex macht
es auf und drinnen ist einfach ein
komplett zerstörtes ältere sony das soll
der park sein
also wenn ihr die idee gut findet lässt
man nur nach oben da und ich muss mir
jetzt nicht ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja gut also man muss sagen was geschenke
einpacken eingebildet jetzt nicht so der
beste aber ich finde es geht klar
jetzt schreibe ich noch drauf das sieht
man ja nicht mehr leute hier steht für
mehr liegen also heißt ja was soll ich
mir machen also ich würde sagen film das
ganze logischerweise also dazu den
päckchen greift dann nehme ich kamera
und filmen dass es könnte auch sein dass
ich einfach film möchte wir was mega
cool dass auspackt also dann ist es ja
eigentlich egal
ich dachte jetzt nicht wirklich auch
versteckte kommen oder so also wundert
euch an der stelle nicht ich hoffe er
checkt nicht von vornherein das ist aber
ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus naja
wünscht mir glück
und jetzt kommt würde ich sagen okay
leute sowie das tier kurzen stopp machen
muss aber ich wollte ich noch was
wichtiges sagen und zwar habe ich
ungefähr vor drei wochen hier auf
instagram dieses video gepostet wo wir
auch so eine aktion von fußballer
aufgerufen habe ist der neuen letzte
beitrag in meinem instagram fehlt also
geht auf jeden fall war gleich rüber
wenn ihr bock habt schaut euch das video
an da geht es einfach darum dass sie
vielleicht irgendwelche sneaker von euch
die nicht mehr braucht oder so einfach
spenden können für den guten zweck ich
finde das mega cool deswegen wollte ich
das einfach noch mal hier im video sagen
weil es deutlich mehr reichweite kriegt
war so kriegt dafür auch kein geld oder
so dass das jetzt so sagen finde ich nur
ganz cool wenn er möglichst viele schuhe
zusammenkommen ich meine jeder mensch
weiß sehr coole schuhe
also schaut doch mal vorbei einfach alex
wie instagram machen wir weiter
[Musik]
willst du nicht erst mal mit dem anfang
das war das leben geschenkt das ist das
hauptgeschäft weiß was das ist
kennst das nicht erkennt kennst du das
ich nicht hätte es gern gehabt dass ich
war aber die paysafecard ist doch schön
oder
so leute also ich hab jetzt wirklich nur
ganz kurz diese szene gefilmt was hat
ausgepackt weil ich finde an weihnachten
sollte jetzt nicht viel für youtube
investieren und so ist ja besser wenn
man da mal die kamera zur seite legt
außerdem gibt es natürlich video für
euch in ruhe das jetzt reflex und zwar
jetzt noch dabei wir stellen uns einfach
eine vorgefasste sprengkraft indianer
und geil ich glaube jetzt so ein
bisschen gezeigt dass halt irgendwas
nicht ganz stimmen kann weil er hat also
gesagt als wenn moment handy schenks für
1200 euro oder so na ja ich fand die
idee trotzdem ganz gut und ich hoffe
natürlich sagt euch gefallen ich frage
mich jetzt nur echte dieses handy ist ja
anscheinend normalerweise werden die auf
den boden fällt so dann ist es ja kaputt
aber bei diesem handy passiert irgendwie
doch jetzt ist was passiert das was
passiert ist würde es mal kurz auf diese
kamera mal gucken aber dass noch kaputt
bekommen und natürlich nochmal die
erinnerung das handy ist komplett
totalschaden
damit kann man nichts mehr anfangen
deswegen macht es jetzt also seid mir
nicht böse
[Musik]
wenn das jetzt nicht kaputt
ich habe es geschafft
ok verriet also einen sony von innen
haus jetzt muss ich immer schon oder in
der software fehler lag nicht also leute
ich hoffe dass wir dadurch gefallen
lassen doch nach oben da macht mit
iphone ich bin gespannt was gewinnt wir
uns wahrscheinlich dann schon morgen
wieder morgen gibt's neues video
captures und instagram snapshot post ich
gerade echt viel also folgt mir da und
ja ich hoffe ihr habt schöne weihnacht
habe ich schon gesagt verbringt viel
zeit mit ihrer familie erst fiel und
lasst euch gut gehen und wir sind rein